-It's nice to
have you here saying
you're optimistic, because
I feel, more often than not,
you show up with some
pessimism,
pessimism that has been founded.
You -- you did predict that
Donald Trump would win.
And --
-Bad news, I know.
-And now, are you worried?
Are you worried about --
'Cause we saw some
very long voting lines
in Georgia yesterday.
How are you feeling,
not just about the outcome
of the election, but the ability
to have an election?
-I'm very worried about this.
We all need to be
very worried about this.
Donald Trump -- again,
I'm, I think,
one of the few people
on the left
that I take him
very seriously.
When he says something,
I actually believe him.
And him putting up this
triple fence wall,
first the big fence,
then the hard fence,
then the cement blocks came.
I mean, this guy really has
a wall fetish clearly now.
-Yeah, he likes walls.
He likes walls a lot.
-He couldn't build one down
on the Mexican border,
so he's going to build it
around the house he lives in.
And like a lot of rich people,
though,
with their gated communities,
he's thinking,
"You know, I'm living here
in a majority-black city.
Where's my gated community?"
So he puts up his gated
community around himself.
But I really think -- you know,
we make jokes about this.
But I think this is a dry run
to the fall.
I'm going to just say this.
I have no inside information.
Eric and Don Jr.
do not confide in me.
But I do believe that
he's now read the polls.
He sees the data.
He's probably going to lose.
He knows it.
And so now he's got to
come up with something.
And the something will be him
trying to postpone the election.
And if we get the second wave
of the pandemic in the fall
where if it's like the second
wave of the flu of 1918,
the second wave killed twice as
many people as the first wave.
So we could have
an awful situation.
And it will make sort of
kind of sense
to just enough people
that, "Yeah,
we really probably shouldn't
have the election.
Let's postpone it."
But in Trump's mind, and the way
people like Trump think is,
once you postpone something,
it's gone.
-Right.
-We can't let that happen
no matter how bad it is.
That's why they're trying to --
the Republicans are trying
to stop the mail-in voting.
Uh, the --
We've seen the story
in Iowa where
the Republican Secretary of
State, the head of elections,
did -- they did mail out things
to everybody in Iowa.
-Ballots.
-Not a ballot.
You got a form.
-Oh, right.
-And you could send
the form back in.
And so they had their largest
turnout ever in a primary
last week in Iowa.
And so all the Republicans
in Iowa are now ganging up
on the Republican
in charge of elections,
saying, "This has got to stop.
We can't do this in November."
'Cause as Trump, again --
honest -- this is
the honest Trump --
said a few weeks ago
something to the effect of --
I'm not going to do
my Trump voice.
We already --
-Thank you. Thank you.
It's like, kind of,
this is my show,
my, you know, yeah --
-It's your --
it's your -- yes.
-Thank you.
[ Laughter ]
-He said, um, that if we just
let everybody vote,
if we make it easy
for everybody to vote,
that's the end
of the Republican Party.
They're not --
"That's the end of me."
He actually said that.
And I thought,
yes, that's right.
Because the majority
of Americans
believe in climate change.
The majority of Americans
believe women should be
paid the same as men.
The majority of Americans
on, and on, and on,
Healthcare for all.
That's who we are as a people.
And we don't want
the Republicans,
or his kind of Republican,
anymore.
They got the message.
Now they got to fix
the election.
They got to rig it.
They've got to wire
this thing up
so that as few people
as possible vote.
So, I think we all need to have
a discussion about this
and right now,
because in order to change
how we're going to vote
on November 3rd,
that's got to be happening
right now.
And it's going to have to happen
in the states.
-I hope people hear
that message.
I do -- would love for you to
come on again as we get closer,
so that we can get what has
so far been very accurate
predictions from you.
So, thank you so much, Michael.
It's always great
talking to you.
-Thank you for having me, Seth.
Thank you, it's been great
watching your show.
And actually the quarantine,
I'm in day, like, 93.
-Yeah.
-And I have learned
some great things.
For instance, I would do
really well under house arrest.
-You think you'd crush it?
-Yes.
I'm never going to be
afraid of that again.
But let's get rid of Trump
so that people like me
are not under house arrest.
Just saying.
-[ Laughs ]
Sounds like a deal.
Thanks, Michael.